cuando un vendedor de materias primas
les dice que el mercado está en contango
se refiere a la idea de que es más
barato comprar hoy es más barato comprar
esa materia prima el día de hoy
es más barato hoy en el mercado de lo
que es acordar comprarla en el futuro
usando un contrato futuro por lo que en
el futuro es más caro es más caro
comprarla
imaginemos que esa materia prima es el
oro para mantenerlo simple vamos a
inventar valores aquí por lo que tengan
en mente que estos no son valores
actuales del oro digamos que hoy ustedes
pueden ir y comprar oro a 1500 dólares
la onza pero si ustedes no quieren
comprar el oro hoy y quieren un contrato
futuro para comprarlo dentro de 1 año
más o menos
digamos que el futuro es un año después
voy a notar esto aquí para tener más
claridad esto es en el mercado presente
y lo compramos por 1500 dólares por onza
y se puede acordar comprarlo un año
después por 1600 dólares la onza así que
para un vendedor esto sería un mercado
en contando lo que quiero señalar es que
esto no es algo tan extraño porque si
ustedes piensan al respecto tienen dos
opciones si quieren invertir en oro el
oro es algo en lo que ustedes van a
querer invertir a largo plazo no lo van
a comer no lo van a usar para que
encienda su auto ni nada por el estilo
así que en la situación con el oro
ustedes lo tendrán definitivamente por
un año pero también para muchos muchos
años así que hay dos formas en que
ustedes pueden invertir en el oro pueden
tomar sus 1500 dólares y comprar el oro
ahora pero si lo hacen así perderán el
retorno de sus 1500 dólares de ese
efectivo que pudieron haberlo invertido
en otros lugares tienen el costo de la
oportunidad
del efectivo ya invirtieron ese efectivo
en un lugar y también tienen que
almacenar ese oro tienen que encontrar
un lugar realmente seguro para guardarlo
para asegurarse de que nadie se los vaya
a robar así que también tienen el costo
de almacenamiento
en general ustedes podrían ahorrarse
ambos costos si entran en un contrato
futuro así que en lugar de gastar 1.500
dólares en el mercado actual para
comprar el oro hoy ustedes pueden tener
este contrato en donde definitivamente
comprarán el oro dentro de un año por
1600 dólares la onza y mientras tanto
pueden tomar sus 1500 dólares y obtener
intereses de ellos obtener intereses y
también se van a ahorrar el costo de
almacenamiento así que de cualquier
manera para el tipo de materias primas
como el oro metales preciosos cosas que
no son consumibles que no se necesitan
para usarse inmediatamente esta opción
no es inusual para que exista en
contando algunas veces ustedes pueden
ver un contango más severo quizás con
algo que sí sea un consumible por
ejemplo puede ser que ahora el petróleo
se esté comprando a 50 dólares el barril
estoy inventando el número en que conste
y el precio futuro esté en 150 dólares
aquí hay más cosas que tomaré
además de el costo de oportunidad y el
costo de almacenamiento lo que pasa aquí
es que en este momento hay mucha
cantidad de consumo de petróleo hoy o
quizás haya alguna percepción de que va
a haber escasez en el futuro así que
puede verse de ambas formas pero es muy
poco usual que esto ocurra en la
realidad este tipo de contango severo es
muy poco usual pueden ver algunos
menores que toman en cuenta estos dos
elementos pero no algo así cuando ocurre
algo así normalmente se puede hacer un
arbitraje y obtener alguna ganancia
asumiendo que ustedes pueden almacenar
el petróleo o tienen petróleo para
vender o comprar